daniel westing möchten viele menschen
greift vielleicht nicht aber viele
andere menschen treffen ohne die maske
und in diverse das wäre mit gruseliger
ehrlich gesagt die ganze zeit da
jemandem gegenüberzusitzen den mann in
die augen blicken kann aber es muss ganz
toll sein ist ganz ganz leise ist was
spektakulär seinem land weiß auch nicht
wo man bei dieser geschichte beginnen
soll cani west ist derzeit in berlin es
ist der bekannteste rapper der megastar
der welt sein neues album sonne hat alle
rekorde gebrochen und er ist jetzt hier
in berlin unterwegs eigentlich mit einer
maske eigentlich unerkannt aber nein das
unglaubliche unsere reporter haben kann
er ist exklusiv begleitet gestern war
taxi und abends war mit dem essen wir
sind mit ihm die hauptstadt gefahren und
haben ihm so einiges gezeigt was man
sehen muss hier zum beispiel gestern
abend so hoher dem soul house im member
club ihr in berlin wo sich das who und
hu trifft oder die diesmal gerne werden
wollen und darunter gerade und macht
sich auf dem weg zum set von jonway
jonway teil 4 wer den film gesehen hat
mit keanu reeves und wie es jetzt zufall
will canori hatte geburtstag hat
geburtstag also heute auch noch aber
auch gestern nacht um zwei oder eins das
war ungefähr die uhrzeit wo er dann zwar
nie getroffen hat kann hier läuft so
gerade rum in der liebe so wahnsinnig
dunkel alles ist dunkel berlin war es
dunkel er ist was er ist es das können
wir bestätigen denn unsere kollegen
waren mit ihm essen und vor allem haben
wir auch das weltexklusiv der erste
interview seit seinem rekord also mit
ihm führen können unfassbar dass man mit
ihm sprechen kann aber er hat sich
gestern auch irgendwie das auto frei
räumen lassen unserer bild reporter
gesagt mach mir die pfandflaschen weg
und den dreckigen teppich dann steige
ich ein also irgendwie dieser rapper
irgendwo zwischen genie und wahnsinn auf
jeden fall jemand der uns fasziniert bei
uns im studio ist unser bild kollege
ibrahim cayet der mann der mit kahn
gestern gesprochen hat und natürlich
darf unsere chefin giannina kirsch auch
nicht fehlen an diesem morgen schön dass
ihr da seid
man weiß wirklich nicht wo man bei
dieser geschichte beginnen soll ich
glaube man merkt meine euphorie für
diese geschichte so nah ist man an einem
mega star
einige von ihnen getroffen aber so
privat und so nah dass man die
pfandflaschen fielen aus dem autor räumt
damit einsteigen kann ist man nie das
ist für mich die geschichte des jahres
bisher denn kann ihm ist der ehemann von
kim kardashian einer der erfolgreichsten
künstler die wir auf dieser welt haben
spaziert durch berlin und wir sind die
ganze zeit bei ihnen an ihm dran
kunstprogramm museumsbesuche abends
schönes grill royal gehen und ein
bisschen schlimm da hat er dann übrigens
auch die maske abgesetzt also er hat
dann doch nicht mitgegessen das ist dass
das kann man sich glaube ich nicht
vorstellen und millionen von fans
müssen so neidisch sein was da jetzt
gerade passiert und ich kann wirklich
sagen dass auch unseren reportern jedem
reporter einfach das herz aufgegangen
ist ich persönlich bin ich der größte
cani west fan aber auch lage und willig
ist dir wer genau das heute gerade
suchen nämlich ins spiel wo ich kannte
diese dunkle seite bisher von dir egal
du bist vielleicht vielleicht einer der
größten kann die west fans auf der welt
ja zumindest hier in diesem studio
aktuell sagt ganz kurz nachdem du ihnen
wir zeigen dass gleich exklusiv gestern
getroffen und gesprochen hast hast du
schlafen können in dieser nacht ganz
ehrlich nein ich habe es wirklich
versucht ich bin ja ein bisschen länger
geblieben weil ich habe ja auch das
gesamte segment ein bisschen aufbereitet
für die sendung und habe währenddessen
immer wieder pausen machen müssen weil
ich nicht darauf klar kam weil ich es
nicht realisiert habe nicht nicht
wahrgenommen habe ich habe gerade eines
meiner größten musikalischen vorbilder
interviewt exklusiv wir sind die ersten
und das ist ein atemberaubendes gefühl
gewesen war dann um drei uhr zu hause
und das krasse ist ich habe ihm nach dem
interview die hand gegeben und um drei
uhr nachts stand ich dann im flur rechts
von mir das bad und geradeaus ging zum
schlafen und ich schaue mir diese hand
an und frage mich soll ich jetzt diese
hand waschen oder nicht gemacht ich habe
es auch wenn du natürlich gemacht aber
trotzdem war das ein erlebnis das wollte
ich jetzt mit ihm mutiert sind
wahrscheinlich wer weiß wie lange diese
hand ungewaschen also ich will noch mal
sagen sag mir bescheid wenn du in deiner
stadt ist und er genauso zugänglich ist
ich würde denn ryan gosling nehmen da
war wir sind aufgeteilt jetzt haben es
aber sehen sein interview mit kanye west
das erste überhaupt das geführt wurde
seitdem er jetzt am wochenende sein
erfolg sein rekord album herausgebracht
hat
meine einzige frage ist was machst du
hier in berlin du hast dein album gerade
erst vor vier tagen rausgehauen also was
machst du ausgerechnet hier wir haben
eine schule architektur entworfen wo
habt ihr sie entworfen in kalifornien
aber wir werden die schule in chicago
bauen um beim wiederaufbau der stadt zu
helfen also bin ich hierher gekommen um
mich mit den verschiedenen architekten
und künstlern in berlin zu treffen um
die beste architektur schaffen und beim
wiederaufbau von chicago helfen zu
können das ist großartig aber warum hast
du dich ausgerechnet für berlin
entschieden nun ja nicolas ist hier und
olaf es hier und einige meiner anderen
lieblings architekten und designer sind
hier in berlin
was hast du als nächstes hier vor und
wie lange wirst du in deutschland
bleiben
ich werde hier nicht allzu lange bleiben
wir werden hier an dem bau einer neuen
schule arbeiten und dann an der neuen
musik an neuer musik ja das ist mein job
hast du für deine neue musik schon ein
datum und kopf oder wirst du dich von
der inspiration treiben lassen
der grund warum ich gott auf diese welt
gesetzt hat ist damit ich musik mache
gott hat demmler auf die welt gesetzt um
zu design gott hat tadao ando auf die
welt gesetzt um architektur zu kreieren
gott hat uns tore geschenkt gott hat uns
matthew barney geschenk gott hat uns
alle aus einem bestimmten grund hinab
gesandt und mein grund ist es soll
dirigent sein und musik produzieren
also wirst du erst über architektur
sprechen und dann musik produzieren hier
in deutschland für zukünftiges songs
ich produziere musik in meinen gedanken
egal wo und
lebt und genau dafür liebe ich ihnen für
diesen ein bisschen größenwahn dieses
bisschen genie ich habe mir ein bisschen
notizen gemacht wenn man muss ja er
redet von sehr viel vor allem die
talente die ihm der liebe gott geschenkt
hat aber die augen der liebe gott hat
uns da an wo das ist übrigens ein
japanischer architekt liebe zu schauen
und zuschauer falls ihnen das sich
sofort in den kopf gegangen ist oder
matthew barney ist ein zeitgenössischer
medienkünstler aus den usa bei uns ist
eben er hat das interview geführt eine
frage an dich was ging dir also durch
den kopf ist so immer gegenüber standes
das war für dich unfalls bei aufregenden
mal sagen du größter fan event überhaupt
ich habe nicht lange gezögert um ehrlich
zu sein also ich hatte um mich herum
paar kollegen die so ein bisschen scheu
waren die sich nicht getraut habe auf
ihn zuzugehen und gott sei dank bin ich
so oft man hat mir gedacht komm wir
machen es jetzt einfach einfach los
machen und wir hören jetzt einfach in
eine weltpremiere rein die uns die du
uns übrigen nämlich auch noch
mitgebracht hat sich jetzt gesagt donner
das rekord album und es gibt einen ganz
ganz neuen song und er würde noch
nirgends gehört werden das glück das
kann us- das gefühl hatte den muss er
uns jetzt auch noch einmal zeigen hier
also eine kleine kostprobe
für die einen mag das nur so ein
bisschen irgendwie da bewegen sich zwei
und es kommt ein bisschen musik aber es
ist wahnsinn es ist es ist vor allem für
für musikkenner für fans von k s ist es
eine riesen ehre dass er das überhaupt
an gespielt hat also gerade so eine
größe wie kann die usa ich habe daraus
gehört dass es nicht er selbst war es
auf jeden fall ein feature gast man muss
aber dazu sagen also jetzt sagt er es
ist es ein exklusiv hit es ist ein song
der noch nicht draußen ist ja es gibt
sich songs die noch draußen sind wenn
wir alle einmal im jahr 2019 uns
anschauen was er alles mit dr dre als
executive producer irgendwie da auf die
beine gestellt hat davon fährt ihr alles
in dollar also das album ahnten nichts
von dr dre sexy clip dass ist ein
bisschen schade oder sagen wir nichts
sagen wir wenig dass ein bisschen schade
also von daher bin ich gespannt ob
dieser saison überhaupt rauskommen wird
trotzdem ist es schön keiner hat gehört
wir waren die ersten
[Musik]